mais qu'en fait c'est un petit oiseau et
vas y à tourner qui pensent que c'est
mon terrain avec ses yeux ébahis voir
rouge et lyon les animaux étaient jeunes
et que peut-être que c'est un pouvoir
pour rigoler pourquoi précieux un tout
petit animaux nous mettez pas il n'était
par terre lune dira c'est un éléphant tu
piques un rhinocéros après le rennais
sera qu il est en train de pleurer il
est en train de crier très coloré et
plein d'imagination un qui voient que
comme un paon de nuit parce que c'est
une preuve il n'ya pas besoin d'être
fort quand on a confiance en soi ça et
moi jamais comme des pouvoirs au début
il avait un chapeau que sa mamie avait
tricoté pour lui
après les autres et sont venus mon dieu
raillard dès qu'il prenait le même là
pour que ses copains passent commande
avait déjà changé chapeau il est plein
de chapeau les autres y viser ringard
elle était rigolo et les chapeaux il est
d'origine ont aimé la dernière page
quand le ch l'avait
et je sortais plus pourquoi j'ai fait
tous les autres rivaux essayé de
l'imiter en fait ce surveillant d'être
la modique qui pourrait juste être toi
même et j'étais déjà bien grand père
s'est levé pour saluer ses deux petites
filles
auxerre belmondo et son grand-père il en
train de méditer espérerait on lui
demande qu'est ce qu'il fait beau mais
quand il a expliqué qu'il médite même le
savoir a comme un rêve et son compère et
lui dit battre il faut pour méditer faut
prendre soin d'eux a retenu on a du mal
à se concentrer
il devait un requin et la joue bien et
de ne pas regarder le courant et les
bras en guise d'hommage outils de dessin
et les jeunes talents que sont pressés
de nous à laval est atteinte
il faut plutôt être calme ce qu il va
s'énerver 50 points